السكريه صراع يومي يعيشه المصابون خاصه من
النوع الاول منه هو مرض مناعي ذاتي يهاجم
فيه الجسم الخلايا المسؤوله عن انتاج
الانسولين ويعاني من السكري بشكل عام اكثر
من نصف مليار شخص حول العالم الخلايا
الجذعيه من احدث طرق علاج السكري تستخدم
في التجارب لانتاج خلايا تفرز الانسولين
ذاتيا دون الاعتماد على الحقن في مناطق
كثيره حول العالم اظهرت التجارب السريريه
ان حقن الخلايا الجذعيه قد يعالج داء
السكري من النوع الاول وان معظم المرضى
المشاركين ودعوا حقن الانسولين لبضع سنوات
الاختبارات تظهر نتائج واعده لعلاج السكري
بالخلايا الجذعيه عند البعض لكن لا يزال
الباحثون يعملون على اجابه اكثر من سؤال
منها ضبط الجرعات المثلى ومنع استهداف
الجهاز المناعي للخلايا الجديده المنتجه
للانسولين
[موسيقى]